when i'm watching a marvel movie i want
to be that
that weird adult in the back of the
theater with his po curled up with his
popcorn
watching a bunch of you know pew pew and
and cgi and people in tight suits
doing you know fantastical [ __ ] i don't
care i don't you know i
don't care i mean you're talking about
comic books it's a medium that features
aliens
and animals you know and robots as as
their
as their main characters so you know i
don't think that the comic book going
audience of the general movie going
audience uh
you know really is in the mood to or
needs to be lectured to
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster
i'm constantine kitten and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today
is a classically trained professional
actor and broadway
veteran clifton duncan welcome to
trigonometry hey what's going on fellas
how you doing today
oh it's great to have you on man uh
we've been looking forward to this chat
for a long time
uh for people who don't know who you are
before we get into the conversation
itself tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that leads you
here talking to
us uh yeah well it's kind of funny
because i'm not somebody who gets
starstruck i've spent the last few years
working with famous people but it is it
is
kind of it gives me tingles inside to
work with people that or not work with
but to talk to people that i watch on
the internet all the time but
yeah you know i'm a classically trained
actor i've been based in new york city
for 15 years
i moved there originally to attend to
attend
conservatory training at nyu's graduate
acting program which is one of the top
three it's you know it's up there with
juilliard and in the yale school of
drama
and uh or jl school of trauma as they
call it and
uh i got out uh
about ten years ago i've been working uh
at the top theaters around the country
i've been off broadway up and on
broadway and
guest starred on several television
series and
for years i've basically been living a
double life and it's it's not
as though i'm some sort of hard right
uh wingnut it's just that uh i
i am not as enamored with the the
quote-unquote progressive train
you know i mean i don't even know what
that word means anymore um
as everyone else in the industry seems
to be and i notice
excuse me i began to notice especially
after trump's uh
election i i likened the i don't know if
you want to call it the left or the
democrats in america but uh
it it's it's like watching a a corpse
writhing in convulsions after receiving
a bullet to the head
and i i notice this
i want to say stench of activism that's
like that's flooding different arenas
and it's not just
the theater world which you know people
complain about hollywood but
it's it's more concentrated in the
theater realm
um but it's also in comic books it's in
video games it's in all these forms of
entertainment and i fear
that um there is too much homogeneity
and
that they're shutting out voices and
that what's going to happen is that
people especially now in an era where
there's so much technology and there's
so many things competing for our
attention we're
i think we're we run the risk of sliding
into irrelevance and obsolescence um
just in our industry and and risk
alienating a lot of people
and i think there's a cultural malaise
that's going on and
people can feel it uh you know that
there's there's a sort of a cultural
death going on but
essentially i started a twitter twitter
account a year ago
and uh started i put my face to it i was
like i'm just gonna say what i think
and um and i've developed a strange
little following which i i find kind of
funny and um
and i actually had a fortuitous meeting
with a young beautiful lady named carrie
smith who you had recently on your show
um it was a time where there were so
many things that were in crisis last
year in america and i just said
someone's got to do something i'm really
stressing out i think
you know i i saw the way that and i'm
sure we'll get into this later but i saw
the way that
uh just specifically you know the black
lives matter movement begins sweeping
through everything including my industry
and
and you know i'm glad that people like
matthew mcconaughey and isaiah
washington
are sort of breaking out but you know
they have careers already
what about people who don't have careers
what about people who are one job away
or who are still just trying who are
journeyman actors you know people like
me
who you know we work but we're not
household names obviously and uh
there's i just think people just need to
speak up and and
you know there's a lot of artists like
like ever since i've been speaking that
people have been reaching out to me
and you know it can't just be me but we
have to
that there needs to be more variety
we're creative people we're supposed to
be expressive and we
and we drive a lot of elements of
culture and right now i think we're
creating a monoculture and
people are just are detaching themselves
because of it and i don't
um that's bad for my industry obviously
and i think it's just bad for the
culture as a whole
that's my spiel well yeah and it's
listen man it's great to have you on the
show because i feel like you're part of
a group of people who are trying to
think for themselves
at a time when that is the worst thing
you can do from a career point of view
right and and that's why we we love
having people like you and kerry and
others on the show who maybe don't have
a huge following but have something
really
interesting and original to say uh and
it's interesting before i ask you the
question the point you made about
journeyman actors i i always felt the
same thing about comedy even ricky
gervais who i've defended recently who's
he's a brilliant writer comedian etc he
always used to say well
there is no problem with free speech and
comedy just say what you want
and then you know if people like it
they're like and if they don't they
don't which is
if you ricky gervais that's absolutely
true
if you're a club comic that is
absolutely not true because as you say
your next gig your next performance
depends on
you know the people in the industry the
gatekeepers allowing you that
opportunity
but let's come back to this idea of
leading a double life because i think
that's really
fascinating what has that been like
being a broadway actor being an actor
more generally and having
you know as you say you're not hard
right i mean you do look really racist
but
[Laughter]
i was trying to hide it i have so much
makeup on right now
i can't conceal it but but you know what
i'm saying like just
trying to think for yourself and also
feeling like you're genuinely
you know you're like in a different
space where you're not allowed to think
for yourself
what's that been like and what what
happens in the acting industry like just
stuff that people
ordinary people wouldn't know about yeah
well it's you know
it it it got to the point especially
after trump got elected where you know i
i would be
at an audition and you know the casting
director would be like can you just can
you believe
what uh what trump did today i'm like
[ __ ] i'm trying to put this job i want
to work on cbs and pay off my student
loans
i don't give i don't care about this
[ __ ] but
but uh but you know marching back a
little bit i mean my my training and i
and i
take a lot of pride um in my in my
training and my pedigree
and you know we learned i was taught
that curiosity and empathy
are two of the cornerstones of the craft
of acting you know the classic example
is if you have to play hitler you know
you don't have to like the guy but you
do have to understand
why he took the actions that he took and
when i see so many people who are
calling themselves actors who are
incapable of expressing either trait uh
politically you know i have a problem
with that
but just in terms of the everyday kind
of thing it's you know you're just
in an industry where you're paid to be
interesting essentially you have to shut
a part of yourself down
and i have conversations with people on
an on a one-to-one basis
and i can i can pick them out now
because there's sort of a deadness
behind the eyes and
i don't say that's a joke i mean it's a
real thing because you can
actively see and sense people who are
cutting off a part of themselves
and the irony one of the paradoxes of
acting is that even though you're using
yourself you know you're using yourself
in
the service of other characters so if
i'm playing uh uh mcduff who is the hero
of of uh macbeth
aka the scottish play you know there's a
scene in the play
one of the central scenes where he
learns that macbeth has slaughtered his
wife and his children
and you have to go through those
emotions every night but you have to
find your own way you know what is it
that makes that triggers these kinds of
emotions this kind of grief this kind of
sorrow in yourself
and if you spend years and years
deadening yourself and deadening your
emotions and not expressing yourself and
essentially lying to yourself
um then you're not going to be able to
lie truthfully for an audience if that
makes any sense
and it just it kills it kills your soul
it kills your artistic spirit you know
that
and and you're sitting in these rooms
these rehearsal studios or you're on set
talking to people and
me it's not and again it's not it's a
i'm i'm a a hard right conservative or
anything like that although
you know i i have i do have my proud
boys tattoo on my on my left
[Laughter]
as my you know as i tap my right you
know it's
but you hear the things that people say
you you you can tell that they've never
bothered to engage with
any sort of uh any heterodox
or or or conservative or libertarian
thinking and they just make these
blanket statements and
at a certain point you realize you know
these people would not piss on me if i
were on fire
and it's not and again it's not as
though i'm dropping bombs and and
talking about jewish conspiracies and
how women shouldn't vote i'm just saying
that
there is you know men are not the same
as women
and i think we should take that into
account and if and if we keep
trying to if we keep ignoring that we're
going to keep imposing these things like
there was
just an example someone was doing
othello and they tried to do a
genderless othello well
one of the story elements in othello is
that you know it's
there's a fraternity of men it's a very
militaristic play
you have these guys who are in the army
and they've been through battle together
and any soldier will tell you that
there's nothing like the bond between
brothers on the battlefield and part of
the play part of the tragedy of the play
is that othello's trust is broken and it
devastates him and it leads to it leads
to him murdering his wife in the last
scene of the play
i mean it's it's that intense and if you
don't
if you don't understand the dynamics
between men and women if you don't if
you try to ignore
the dynamics among men and those kinds
of emotions that that can
you know loyalty brotherhood that that
and how what that means for those to be
broken
um you're going to uh dramatically blunt
the
the potency of the peace and you know
and and i just think that in an industry
where you're supposed to be creative and
you're supposed to be interesting you
need to allow
all kinds of opinions and views and and
if you're only coming from one
perspective i mean i've been in room so
many times where i'm like
i'll give you an example um i was doing
a show off broadway and it was a revival
of
a a it was a pretty big deal and
it was one of those things where i said
well you know men and women are in the
workforce for the first it was that 1947
and just me even saying that men and
women being in the workforce together at
the same time for the first time and and
beginning to try to begin a dialogue
from a rehearsal and a storytelling
standpoint of
how can we as actors activate this see
this tension between
the men and women who are working
together maybe for the first time
they're not used to being around each
other what does that mean how do they
navigate that
i mean it's it's it's nerdy actor stuff
but it's the kind of stuff that we do
the kind of thought we put into what we
do so that
when you guys sit there and you want to
disconnect for a couple of hours you can
get swept away and wrapped up and
wrapped up in it
and um but it became this thing like no
women have always been working
i'm not i'm not insulting women i'm
trying to
to you know and and but that's what it
is you're pushing up against this
orthodoxy and i've and i've been saying
this for years
it's a secular religion now and and if
you
if you say anything about you know
whiteness is the original sin
hell is the cis heteronormative
patriarchy heaven is a feminist utopia
and
god is a black transgender quadriplegic
and a hijab
it's a it's a strange religion but
yeah and you you express that
beautifully because
i am a similar background to you i went
to one of these conservatoires i
i then taught drama for for yeah for a
long time
um i love the way even the american
actor is making fun of you trying to
sound posh it's great
yeah i went to the central school of
speech and trauma darling
amazing i mean we can bond over that and
gin and tonics
but the questions yeah exactly
um the question that i wanted to ask
clifton is this it's
the actors that i love the ones that i
worshipped when i was wanting to do it
were people like richard harris the
peter o'tooles
you know the richard burton's the hell
raisers the people who took life by the
balls and
lived every moment of it and then when
you saw them on screen it
imbued their performance with such a
life why is it we've now fallen in love
with the conformist and the insipid as
artists
isn't that what we're meant to be
railing against well that's that's
exactly how i feel about it
i i love richard burton and you read
about him the sort of life that he led
and you know and
these people who are so full of life and
vitality and i think part of the reason
you know it's one of the reasons that
you don't see it on you know a lawrence
olivier or something or someone who's
that dynamic you know i either
it's we don't have a culture now that
has need for or produces these kinds of
of
of artists um in my opinion or
or and or you know i mean i've been told
often times you know about my vitality
and i enjoy being on stage and i love
filling a huge theater and just being
you know big in so many ways but
but also i recognize that increasingly
i'm in an industry where just as a
male uh there is a
and then someone who is a proudly
masculine male uh you know there's this
a a pushback and a lack of
uh consideration for for what that means
and the power of that
and uh so i i feel like that sort of
heat that sort of fire that that that we
love in our favorite actors i mean it's
it's been
sort of pushed out of the industry as
it's been taken over by these other
people who
and i don't want to say taken over but
you know because part of it is just it's
it's almost an organic process
in a way just thinking of the time the
types of people that are drawn to
careers in the arts
but uh you know there's
i don't know if we have the culture and
then the iron the irony is then
you know we keep hiring australian
actors or british actors or whatever who
aren't maybe as
uh you know i mean we we have our we
have our chris hemsworth's you know who
who come over
our our henry cavills our russell crows
and everything and it's like and i asked
my manager actually and she did miss a
beat when she answered i said why are we
hiring hiring all of these
why why are these europeans and these uh
aussies taking our jobs
and uh and she was just and she just she
just said you know they're more manly
that was it you know and it's i feel
like it's an open secret
and and i and i feel like you know when
you see
actors like jason momoa enjoy such
success
i mean there there's a reason for that
and i i feel like what hollywood figured
out a long time ago is that men and
women will pay it's it's
maybe partly biological but i think also
just pure economics where
men and women will pay money to go see
people that they find attractive and
interesting on the screen
and um and part of your attractiveness
as a man has
doesn't have as much to do with you know
your physical appearance as it has to do
with you know
what what what do you have going on
inside and what kind of fire do you have
you know are you defiant
you know do you stand up for yourself
are you funny are you smart
are you quirky and um you know i think
when you have an industry where
um increasingly these types of
traits aren't valued and you and you
have to constantly sort of censor
yourself and so much about it and so
much
so much about what we do now is about
being kind and as harmless as possible
and i was taught that you know you want
to be bold and dangerous
you want to take risks in your art i
mean that's our favorite comedians do
that
all the best actors do that you know
they they say outrageous things or
daring things or they go
places emotionally that you're like oof
i don't i don't want to be there you
know i'm glad i wasn't on set that day
that might have been kind of awkward
um but there's just not as much of a
a push for that and i feel and i feel
like audiences even if they can't
articulate that i feel like they feel
that
and that worries me and the other thing
that worries me is the fact that
whenever i watch certain programs now
more and more
i just feel that i'm being lectured to
why does
art and entertainment have to be a
lecture why does it have to be political
i mean some of it certainly can be and
somebody all right dial down the white
fragility
no you can just all you can hear clifton
on my white tears hitting the floor
i don't know i don't know but but why is
that
you know well it goes back to what i
said about it it's it's more of a
religion than anything else it's it's an
orthodoxy i just had this thought last
night that uh
tyler perry who your countrymen may not
be familiar with he said he's a black
american
uh filmmaker and sort of mogul who began
his career doing uh stage plays
what are called chitlin circuit plays
which you know they appeal to a very
specific
demographic and you know he had this
character called medea you know he
basically
it's like the black missed out fire in a
way dresses in drag sort of violent and
and uh you know people have a lot of
things to say about tyler perry you know
i
i you know i'm not his target audience
but i do appreciate his talent and
you know you can have nothing but
respect for the for the guy who i mean
he's one of the few people right now
he's here in atlanta you know he has a
whole studio movie studio that's
operating right now
um during during uh during the time of
covid and he's built i mean he's a
billionaire i mean he's really forged
his own path in the entertainment
industry but the thing about his place
that's
that you know he's very very christian
and he's deeply religious
and so what you see is when you when you
watch his plays or his films
not saying that your audience has to go
and and and do that
but there's a point there's always a
point
where the narrative stops dead in its
tracks and
the character either bursts into song to
sing about jesus
or some other character begins to talk
about you know
we need to just pray right now and
praise god and this sort of a thing and
i feel like that's how people
feel you know maybe on a subconscious
level when they when they're watching
their
you know their favorite movie and i mean
prime example
uh in avengers infinity war uh you know
i i i love that movie to death and
there's that great scene
when they're batting that climactic
wakanda battle scene
where it's uh it's you know scarlett
johansson and danai guerrero who's a
graduate of the school that i went to
and she's amazing
and uh and uh elizabeth olsen and you
know it's like the girls and then they
have like the female uh
thanos uh demon or i can't remember what
her name is and
and in a way you're like oh snap it's a
cat fight and it's a cool scene
and then you fast forward to avengers
endgame and everyone knows the moment
that i'm about to reference where
they're in that climactic battle with
thanos like the world is ending
you know if everything is going bad and
then i i forgot who which character it
was it's one of the female superheroes
and she's like down and
and then like she needs help and all the
the female characters
you know who are they suddenly find
themselves converging all in the same
spot during this climactic battle with
all of thanos's like you know
henchmen and demons there's this huge
war going on but they all find a moment
to unite together and have this girl
power moment where it's like you know
she has help and it's all slow motion
and
and people just watch it and they're
like oh man come on
it's just you you've stopped the plot
and
the forward progression of the story to
preach to me about how women are great
in a manner similar to now we're
stopping this tyler perry show
to preach to the audience about how god
is great
and i i think that people that you know
if they want to be sermonized to they'll
go to church
you know when i'm when i'm watching a
marvel movie i want to be that
that weird adult in the back of the
theater with his pop curled up with his
popcorn
watching a bunch of you know pew pew and
and cgi and people in tight suits
doing you know fantastical [ __ ] i don't
care i don't you know i don't care
i mean you're talking about comic books
it's a medium that features aliens
and animals you know and robots as as
their
as their main characters so you know i
don't think that the comic book going
audience of a general movie going
audience uh
you know really is in the mood to or
needs to be lectured to about how
wonderful women are i think a lot of
them kind of feel that way and you know
and
we're inhibiting our storytelling
ability and prowess by
continuing to inject these sorts of it's
a great point
and the thing that makes some of these
characters really fascinating like if
you take
marvel like for instance uh tony stark
or if you go back towards shakespeare
it's the fact that our heroes are flawed
that's where the interesting thing is
that they have the heroic qualities
but they also have their flaws whatever
hero is whether it's someone like hamlet
who's
you know filled with hubris and
pomposity or work whatever it may be
and it just seems that more and more
we've just got these archetypes that are
constantly
presented to us yeah it's um
you know but but they're archetypes that
aren't really tied to anything that we
recognize as human
exactly you know yeah that's exactly
what i was thinking when francis said
archetypes because i was like well they
are archetypes but they have no
resemblance to anything real right yeah
so the archetype of masculinity and
femininity
that we are now being presented with you
know that's the issue that you raise
has no bearing on how men and women
actually
show themselves in the world right
that's the interesting thing here isn't
it
yeah you know it and it's that's why
it's just so and again i feel like
audiences know that and they
and they and they feel that and they're
not interested in it and and and it's
also in in a way it's
it's sort of insulting to them you know
i there's a
there's a series that that i auditioned
for
and you know it was like this this elite
in a new
set in a space station you know and it
was one of those things where you know
surprisingly all the positions of
command were filled by
by women and and uh there was one scene
it was a flashback where the character i
was auditioning for
was uh was with his uh then partner his
spouse
and there's a scene where you know it
and it says you know in the script
you know these are two people who are in
peak physical condition and
and um so you have this man and this
woman and they and they
finish up whatever run they're doing and
they start sprinting and it's so it was
it's so hilarious because i'm reading
this and
i'm like okay they're sprinting and i
feel like i know it's coming and then in
italics it's like
and she wins i'm like hold on a second
hold on a second like like i ran track
in high school i still or athletics as
it's called overseas where people can
actually make money doing it
and i i said wait a minute now i
i know the differential if you're a
woman and you can run the 200 meter dash
in under 22 seconds that's world class
but if you're a man and you can't and
you cannot like if you run that same
time you'll get the doors blown off of
you by
high schoolers you know and so so when i
auditioned for it i just pretended that
i got a cramp or something like that
because that's the only way that i as an
actor can justify
that i that i in peak physical condition
who you know who knows how to run and
who is in shape and you know knows
proper form and everything
there's no i'm sorry like you ain't
gonna beat the girl's not gonna beat me
unless something happens and i'm like
and you know i've auditioned for for
things where it's like you know
i'm a special especially trained special
forces agent but somehow i lose
in a combat in combat to my smaller
female counterpart and the irony of it
is
you begin to see how these sorts of they
begin to push so far in single
directions that that then these
begin to cross over into uh weird areas
for political correctness so
is isn't that kind of strange that you
you know you're so dedicated to uh to
female empowerment that you have this
small white woman beating the [ __ ] out
of a black man
that's sort of strange isn't it
isn't it isn't it isn't it kind of weird
that you know there's another show
come on brother don't stand in the way
of progress a small white woman beating
up a black guy is exactly what progress
is all about
you need to acknowledge it we
we we've come so far just to come but
you know but there's another example of
of uh you know there's a show it's one
of these sort of body positivity thing
and i can go on a rant about you know
about that for a long time but
you know it was like i i was auditioning
for it as this black
british you know fit you know handsome
guy who wanted to really who really
really wanted to have sex with the
the female lead who was this like
overweight
you know white woman and you know and i
see what they're trying to do i know
what they're
i know the message they're trying to
send but again me as a as someone
watching this i'm like okay
if you're a big tall sexy british guy
you're going to be slaying all kinds of
american [ __ ] you're not going to like
wait up
for you know for it for for this
i mean so if he's
because because you have to be real you
have to be honest
it doesn't you know what i'm serious
though because it doesn't take away from
like you know like
i appreciate that that human beings are
are vastly adaptable and multi-varied
species and not and that not everybody
fits into
uh uh you know traditional boxes or
whatever and that and that and i think
that's cool
it's just that don't don't tell don't
try to
don't try to get me to lie stop getting
me to lie about this [ __ ] because
it it it denigrates the work and and
it's insulting again to the audience
because they can see it as well just
stop lying and they're not watching it
look at the ratings for shows like
doctor who
or supergirl or uh or or star trek or
star wars you know the the
these franchises are now losing money
and um it's because people are watching
these things and they're saying
this is not true and even though you say
well it's star wars
star trek or whatever it's science
fiction but yeah the reasons that those
stories work is because they
are rooted in things that we know are
true it's why we still do greek plays we
still do shakespeare we still do check
off
because they're rooted in plans and
human truths that we know
and you know and and it's not that you
can't tell stories you know from
an alternative point of view there was a
play that was recently done at new york
city's lincoln center which is one of
the most prestigious theaters here
and i can't remember the name of it but
it was set in uganda the main characters
were gay
and if people don't know i believe it's
still uh
criminal to be homosexual in uganda and
the play was this
really tense suspenseful piece about
this
about how these two central characters
these two men they're in love
and they have to hide it but there's all
this pressure from the government from
their families you know and it's a
really taught drama
you know like we want but it's rooted in
this thing of like okay people trying to
be themselves
and try and and they're in love we want
to see people in love but then how do
they
fight off all these oppressive forces
what's going to happen these people are
in danger are they going to make it
that's that's what we want to watch we
don't care if they're gay or not we
don't care if they're trans or not
there's a
film called pariah that came out years
ago
it was a black it was a coming-of-age
story about a young black lesbian in new
york city
you know and and all the familial
turmoil and you know discovering herself
and finding herself that we've all went
through because we've all been through
puberty
or a gun hill road the coming of age
story about a young latino transgender
who's going from male to female it's the
same sort of thing you know awkward
awkward love scenes she's trying to find
herself and you know and date and figure
out who they are
these are things that we can that we can
all watch and all key into but
i think they i think people are so stuck
on this idea that i have to
put this message in there and teach
people that you know it's like no just
don't teach me you know don't don't the
classic saying is don't tell me show me
just show me have you ever been abroad
and felt
out of place because you didn't speak
the language no because i voted brexit
brexit means brexit i know that
sometimes you're abroad you don't speak
the local language it's very awkward
like france is talking to a woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and easy to use
interface they have daily 10 to 15
minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up or maybe you're
just
english right now babel is offering our
fans
six months free on a six-month
subscription with babel
using our special code which is of
course trigger
that's babble b a b b
e l dot co dot uk
play and use the promo code trigger look
at that spelling he learned english on
babel
i did but seriously go to babble.com uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
and it's a great point because there
comes a point where they put
this type of messaging in and it becomes
so patronizing
that it actually becomes offensive i
think that with the shot i never watched
it but i read a lot about it was called
hollywood
and it was sort of a woke reimagining of
what hollywood was like during the
golden age in the 50s
and they had this sort of reimagining of
rock hudson who was a closeted gay man
and was the first
celebrity to die of aids and
people who are close to him actually got
very upset about it because they were
like you're tarnishing his legacy
by saying oh this you know woke
reimagining you're not
understanding the struggle that he had
and the fact that he could never be
honest about who he was
to the point that it it actually becomes
offensive
because you're whitewashing his life in
his existence
yeah yeah and it's just that story you
know of course
i i want to see that movie what what is
the psychological toll on a rock hudson
of having to
uh having to hide who he is i mean you
know and remain in the closet as it were
as
as many people politically do right now
in the industry um
another another example i think of uh is
it's a wonderful life you know it's
it's one of my favorite movies when i
first saw it i mean i ugly cried for
about an hour afterward
and um come to find out that frank capra
who made the film
is a conservative republican which i had
no idea when i was watching it and you
know and i'm an atheist but i'm sitting
here
being deeply moved by this film which
starts out the opening scene is angels
talking in space the the pivotal plot
moment is
a guardian angel comes down and pretty
much saves jimmy stewart's life
and uh and i'm like how many how many
other
it's a wonderful lives are we keeping
out of the industry and how many
experiences are we robbing
uh potential audiences of you know these
kinds of catharsis
um by by instead saying that you know we
have to teach
these people how they're supposed to be
no one goes
to watch the movie to learn how they're
supposed to be
um that's that's not that's not my job
my job is
is to entertain so you can kind of sit
and forget the drudgery of your life for
a little bit
and you know laugh you know or or be
amazed or astounded or something clifton
i'm curious to ask
change tacky a little bit uh and coming
back to the industry itself
uh what is it like being black uh and
what i mean by that
is well i mean that's a great [ __ ]
question can i just say
when he asks that question i want anton
the producer to edit me out
i don't want to be associated hey i just
want to know what it's like man
the lived experience no but seriously
you know the reason you're just
turkey the reason i'm asking is that
you know in the comedy world like i
would find myself where
in the space of 24 hours i would be
discriminated against for being
dark-skinned and then later that day i'd
be having a conversation with somebody
in the comedy world who'd be like
well yeah i'm sorry we don't need any
more straight white men like you
right so there's all this like
tokenization that's happening
did you find that when you were working
that
more was made of your race than than you
made of it frankly
you know i i think so
and um you know i've been thinking a lot
about this in terms of uh
how you know i mean i did the the irony
is i did not
really think of my race until i began i
began acting
and um if i may you know talk a little
bit at length about it
um
my journey with this you know i i first
went to grad school
and it's a three-year program and
that that first year i was very obsessed
with
hey did i lose you you guys are frozen
no no we're here we're here we're here
we're here
it's okay maybe maybe it's just francis
is just desperately trying not to be
racist
so he's frozen in space
he's like i'm it's the white gays i'm
looking at him
um but my you know my first year
you know i i was very obsessed with this
idea
that you know i mean because i sing and
i rap as well and i was like i don't
want to be the black guy in class
who sings and raps that's so
stereotypical you know i'm smart and i'm
articulate and you know
and so it became this thing where i was
trying to prove to everyone else
in a weird way that i'm not who i am and
over a certain period i had this
experience at this prestigious uh um
uh summer theater up in the berkshires
and there was a point where
i said you know what if
other people cannot see me as anything
other than a black man
that is their problem i'm a human being
first
i'm not my demographic or whatever label
you what you might assign to me
and it was sort of driven home to me
like this last night i'm there
and i'm in this dorm room and you know
there's a bunch of white people that are
you know that are gathered outside um
singing around a bonfire and you know
and i'm like you know if you're gonna if
you've got a bunch of white folks
together like somebody's gonna have a
guitar
and there's gonna be a bonfire build
probably and i'm sitting here
in my room just like man they don't
understand me they you know they don't
you know i'm a black man they don't
really get me yeah and i said wait a
minute i'm sitting in here by myself
feeling like a loser wanting to jump out
the window you know head first
they're having the time of their lives
you know i realize that i'm the one
who's putting these barriers up
i'm the one who is presuming
their hostility towards me so then i
went out there and when i joined them
finally they
you know they were so excited and it was
just a great time and that was a big
lesson for me of
you know this idea that you know the
world is out to get me
and that uh and that other people are
obligated to just
accept me as i am as opposed to me
coming halfway you know maybe i could
learn about your culture
you know maybe i can learn your favorite
beatles songs or your you know or or bob
dylan and expand my repertoire
and i can tell you about you know a
tribe called quest or talib quality or
something like oh we can let people i
mean
they're already listening to that you
know white people love these people but
um so that was that was part of the
the evolution and um
slowly i began to evolve from worrying
a lot about what black people in the
audience might think of me
um to just not giving a [ __ ] because
prime example i played caliban um in
washington dc
and you know caliban for those who don't
know is a slave he is explicitly a slave
in shakespeare's the tempest and you
know my costume i
literally had chains on me you know what
i mean and i knew going in like oh boy
this is going to be
really interesting but i was the one in
the rehearsal room who was like yeah man
like whip me around throw me around like
do whatever you want like abuse me
let's go for it 100 everyone else was
very afraid of it
and then later on people who you know
people who don't know the plot
uh a caliban you know that this pitiful
slave is
you know he meets these two wacky
characters who are basically clowns and
he ends up worshiping them as like gods
to save him essentially
and so i'm like kissing this white man's
foot on stage we had high school
matinees we had these black kids from dc
washington dc public schools who were
just like
and and i'm like you know what man but
that's in the play that's what the
script is
and and i can't stop whatever baggage
people are gonna bring to it and people
still complained
rather than me playing one of the great
roles in shakespeare and doing it well
you know i have the receipts you know
people complain that i can't believe
that they have this black man here in dc
playing a slave ignoring the fact that
there was another black male
actor in the cast who was playing the
son of the king of naples who we thought
was dead which means
this [ __ ] is now the king of naples
he's royalty
he's royalty and they're like but he's
like you know there's a scene in the
tempest where
uh uh prospero the main wizard you know
character
forces this prince to you know just do
menial
slave labor just to test you know who he
is and you know because he wants
to court off his daughter you know it's
one of those old shakespeare plays and
i'm like you have this black man playing
a slave and this other black man who's
also doing slave work i'm like he's the
king he's the king right now
but you're ignoring that because all you
see is is black people so
i i you know i just i i release myself
from this pressure to be a certain type
of way for an audience
but on top of that you know there's the
question of skill set and this idea of
this this myth that uh you know what
black men only get seen for certain
types of roles and i'm thinking to
myself okay well i speak a certain way
i learned how to do shakespeare i
learned how to handle you know
complex texts and those those skills uh
they they fan outwards so if you know
how to do if you can work your way
through hamlet or cymbeline one of
shakespeare's later plays which is
really [ __ ] weird uh you can pick up
a piece of legal jargon from a
procedural
or or a medical procedural and and
activate it to make it interesting you
know and
so when i hear people come to me be like
man black people you know they're not
getting seen in these roles i'm like
well
you know have you worked on your skill
set and
you know have you made yourself more
hirable but i found myself in this weird
position now where
i really feel like a diversity hire and
it's not because i have this
the the chops and the experience you
know i could i can
i can do oscar wilde i can do
shakespeare i can do check off i can do
august wilson
i can do on camera work i can do a
broadway musical
um i have these skills and this
versatility but you're only
hiring me here because you wanted to
have a you wanted to have the picture of
a black person on stage i was working on
a
a show that was supposed to go to
broadway where my character was a
humpback
and i i was totally you know friends
will get this i totally went like
richard iii on i was like you know ah
you know and and the director was like
maybe not so much
but uh you know maybe it's more
psychological and i said okay and then
he said
and he goes well you know clifton he was
he was a british really bad accent right
now
but he just said he's like it might be
that in this era
people might view your skin color
as a handicap and i was like
what what are you talking about you know
it's it's it's this weird
and they chased me so hard for this role
and at that moment i began to realize oh
wait a minute so they have my friend
who's playing the servant mate who's a
black woman who's a very dynamic
performer she's down here in atlanta
with me actually
um a broadway caliber performer and
but then you said holy [ __ ] we have a
black woman playing the maid
i guess we better have a black guy to
play the master of the estate
and in that moment i felt like
okay you know
i mean at the time i mean i made my
broadway debut in a play called um
you may have heard of it called the play
that goes wrong and i'm doing it yeah
yeah
yeah it's a british force it's it's a
british farce right so they should be
done
theater yeah see there we go um you're
just as gay as i am francis
no but but so they brought it over to
broadway and they replaced the
the the original british cast with an
american cast and so i'm doing every
night i'm literally you know
doing upper crust you know uh standard
uh standard british i'm doing the accent
you know it's
and i've had so much practice doing it
and yet it's not that i have that skill
set that i have this
sort of dramatic darkness and i have
this you know baritone voice and
i i have a great blend of vulnerability
and
and and danger and and humor that i can
bring into a role it's
uh you know it's this black guy it's not
it's not it's not that i have years of
experience and dedication in this you
know and again
i say i take pride in it you know people
look down on actors and i understand why
but
you know there are those of us out there
who just genuinely enjoy what we do and
we enjoy
performing for audiences and and it's
and there's a process and a craft that
goes into it and
when you study for a long time to become
good at it a great personal and
financial sacrifice by the way i mean
i could be married by now i could have
children by now but we both wanted to be
actors and so we decided to go our
separate ways i've given up so much and
for you to tell me that i'm only here
you know because you wanted somebody
who's i mean you know this is not
another show that they wanted to see me
for for broadway replacement
the musical and they and the
conversation
as was related to me by my manager
literally was
we should have a black guy playing this
role
so the consideration isn't oh this
they're here's someone who could bring
something
dynamic and interesting and and fresh to
this romantic lead
uh no it's time for a black person to
have this
here take this [ __ ] you you deserve
this
here's a pat here's a pat on the head
and that's how it feels so
it's this very weird thing where it's
like i have the skill set and the craft
and the chops to do these things you're
asking me to do but i feel like
in way i feel like in many ways i'm only
being asked to to do these things
so that white progressives can feel
better about themselves
and that's it's really condescending as
you might imagine
yeah i can certainly get that and why
it'd be utterly infuriating
the one aspect of this whole argument
why have a well i have
sympathy with the progressives is when
they talk about stories coming from you
know different people different voices
whether you know it's you know from a
female writer black writer trans writer
whatever it may be
stories that we haven't heard before
because
i think having like for instance uh a
black
a black mermaid in the little mermaid is
tokenistic and patronizing
but having a different voice with a
different point of view telling a
different story i think there's
definitely merit in that and possibly
something we haven't seen enough of what
do you think
i mean i feel the exact same way you
know it and and
that's why you know it's like you don't
need to preach to people um
i think that uh you know again
i go back to films like pariah or gun
hill road or there was a more recent one
by a filmmaker named greta gerwig
called lady bird um which as i was
watching it i realized i've never seen a
coming-of-age story
told from a woman's perspective and
i you know and it was so refreshing and
enlightening for me
to to see things from that perspective
and and my attitude is if the
storytelling is good
and the storytelling works um you know
please like we're always looking for
something new and interesting and we
just we
i i it's saddening to me
that people feel that they're so hated
and they're you know
especially now in in an age where i mean
you can go to youtube
and you can watch videos that have
millions of views of
of god of a guy who trains mongooses and
dogs to catch rats
and you can watch that for hours you
know like we
if it's interesting and compelling to us
we like we will watch it
and you
i i just feel as though
you maybe can't expect to reach a huge
audience if you're
going for more niche topics but i don't
think there's
i also don't think there's very many
people who are gonna who are actively
saying well i don't want to hear
uh trans voices i don't want to hear
this i don't want to hear that i mean i
think
i think people even if they think it's
weird and that is something that you
have to kind of kind of deal with
uh you know people want to be
entertained they want to be
shown something new and i think if we do
that
from that perspective and again rooted
in something that is that is
that is recognizable to us as human
truth then you'll you'll get a lot
further than
than not i think i don't know if it
really answers your your question but
that's just what i think off the top of
my head yeah it's an interesting point
clifford and there's something you
mentioned right at the top
which i'd like to get into in the sort
of last quarter an hour that we have
together
which is you reference the cultural
death and the cultural decline and this
is something that
i've been thinking a lot about over the
last couple of years
and sensing it i it's a feeling more
than you know i'm sort of
becoming very woke as i talk about it
because i'm it's all about how i
experience things
but that i'm not
like i haven't been to the cinema for
years now
are you i used to have a card that
allowed me to watch as many
as many movies as i could in a month
because that's how much i love
great cinema i haven't been to a movie
theater as you guys would say for years
because
every time i look at the trailers or
whatever i'm not seeing anything that
interesting
you know it's very very rare for me to
see something that's been made in the
last few years that i really like
and everything i look at whether it's
literature whether it's comedy
it there is a decline happening i think
it's very difficult to argue that there
isn't there's still great stuff coming
out but it
it's increasingly more rare what
what do you think that is about if you
agree with me that it's happening
i
i mean it's a very it's a very difficult
thing to
to kind of break down but i i do agree
that there is
i mean even when i go back to marvel you
know it
i i'm someone who really really enjoys
these movies but i also realize that
these are adaptations of stories that
are decades old in many cases
um sorry before you continue there was
that graph recently wasn't there where
like literally like 70 percent of the
movies that have been made in the last
five years are either remakes or sequels
so i mean the creation of new storylines
is just so limited
yeah and and i wonder if part of it i
wonder if part of it
is again this ideological homogeneity
within
uh within the major sectors of of the
industry that that is
that is preventing fresh ideas from
bubbling up to the surface i think maybe
that's part
of it um
i think part of it also is the
advancement in technology in a weird way
it like it is amazing to see thanos on
screen and you can see
you know if you look closely like
stubble on his hair and on his
on his chin from when he hasn't you know
shaved in a couple of days and it's such
a great detail
and and the cgi work is so amazing but
at the same time
i can go back and watch the empire
strikes back and
the the practical effects in these films
i think is
something that helps draw you in more
and so and i see this with music as well
it's so highly digitized now it's so
it's so heavily produced and it's so
electronic that it's sounding less and
less like a human being um
if i look at comic book art you know
it's so much of it is digitized and you
you can't see the scritch marks or the
brush strokes or whatever that that you
might see on an oil painting or
something like that
so i wonder if part of it is technic is
technology advancing
uh so to the point where we are
uh we're just we're sort of
disconnecting
from from what it means to be human in a
way or
or or sen or sentience maybe i mean uh
john mcwhorter put out a piece in
the atlantic where it's oddly enough i
thought the most
salient part of the of the essay was
was what he spent the least amount of
time on which is the the alienation of
modern life
you know as as we become more uh
connected we also become more distant in
a weird way
you know when i was a kid you played you
know nintendo or
famicom or whatever uh it might be and
you know you went over to your buddy's
house you you played
mega man or double dragon or whatever
and you got bored and you went outside
and you skinned your knees and got dirty
now you can play with your friends over
the internet and you don't really have
to meet up anywhere there's so many
forms of entertainment where we can just
be
you know in our phones and not really
connecting with each other
um i think it goes back into what we're
saying about uh about archetypes and
this sort of new orthodoxy where you
know it's all about being harmless
and all about treating others with
kindness which entails you know on one
hand it's great
for civilization and and social order
but at the same time you know
it might maybe it goes too far and that
we are tamping down things about
ourselves i mean
you know we the the sex in ourselves
that the danger the violence
um we're so dedicated to being good that
we're forgetting what's
what's interesting maybe and
on top of that i think culturally
there's
this shift that is
you know i'm going to bring up the the
end the m word i almost
almost said the n word that's that's not
the right thing
well then well nihilism that that is an
n word that i feel like
um is applicable to this sense and
there's a great i mean
and i i wish i were i were more
articulate about this i mean there's so
many things that i like to think about
but uh i i i don't
know if we maybe we're so comfortable
that we're so that we and uh that we in
a weird way are removed from what it
means to actually live and and
and this also kind of it it folds into
the the response to cobit for me in a
lot of ways as well
you know how how can people be so
how can people be so callous about
throwing away first dates
or or hanging out with your buds or
you know playing with your kids in a
park you know how
these these things that make it valuable
to be alive while we're
while we're here shuffling our you know
couple of hours on on live stage
um there seems to be a disconnect
between
what really makes us alive and vital and
and
and preserving what that is and maybe
part of it is because we're so dedicated
now to breaking all these cultural norms
that we're forgetting
uh what these norms are rooted in the
first place i mean i really don't know i
wish i had a better answer for that but
i do feel it and i i sense that a lot of
other people feel it as well they say we
don't
they say we don't they either say we
don't want these reboots or they're
saying i don't
you know i don't watch movies anymore i
don't i don't watch tv i mean
i'm in new york city i have friends in
you know these
hit shows i don't even go to see shows
anymore because i feel like
they're just i felt like they were
making shows for themselves to please
their audience but then they turn around
and say well why can't we get more
subscriptions why can't we get more
people come
coming to see our shows um you know i
i just i don't i don't know i'm not
making a clear point but
but i feel like we all feel it i mean i
i'm with you constantine it's just
there's something that that is amiss and
it makes it difficult to
uh to be optimistic about about the
future sometimes to be quite honest well
listen you've been very articulate
actually and i i didn't want to
interrupt you by
reassuring you that you're articulate
because that would definitely be racist
telling
black man that he is articulate but but
listen what i wanted to ask you before
we get to our last question is
first of all i want to thank you for
coming on the show and i want to say
that
you know i think it's so important for
people like you to to think about these
things and to speak about these things
and i hope that you get into in addition
to the acting which i hope you get lots
more of
uh you get into talking about stuff as
well
um you're looking very skeptical about
the possibility of you doing more acting
but i do hope it happens
yeah it's not i don't know at this point
you know at every every time i hit the
tweet button
it i do so with a bit of i i live with
like this chronic low grade
paranoia and anxiety uh you know and i
just
and i shouldn't i feel like i shouldn't
have to feel that way because again
i'm not out there saying that uh
you know i mean i'm not out there saying
extreme things i'm just you know
saying saying what i think and but you
know i tweeted out the other day that i
am moving
into content creation i have to get you
know all my gear set up and everything
and move into this new realm i you know
i
i don't think there's enough performers
who take advantage of these kinds of
technologies
uh as it is but you know but it's also
difficult i just
as much as i try i just i can't shut up
about this stuff it's really important
to me
and um i i don't i don't know why i just
don't know why but i can't stop talking
about these things i see
i see this stuff and um
i just i just want to i just want to
talk about it and um and it's
it's gratifying in a way because i have
artists who reach out to me privately
now
who are saying you know thank you and
people who are in la
people who are in new york um they say
thank you
but they say you know but i can't speak
up right now and
you know and i i sort of understand how
people feel now when they say
when they say that they feel that they
have a little less tolerance now for
people who are who are afraid to say
anything because
at a certain point you're like look i i
understand you're afraid but
what's worse you know you you lose your
career or your job
or you know i mean you can find another
one or that you keep allowing this to
continue and and
there's long-term damage that we're not
seeing right now but that
but that is but that's accruing um you
know i just i
i don't know what it what's driving me
to be honest but there's just something
in me that that doesn't
that just can't stay silent uh
especially during times like this
that's why thanks for having me no but
well that's
why we wanted to have you on the show
because i think when people
uh as articulate and who think as
carefully about these things as you do
want to speak that has to be encouraged
and it has to be supported so i
thoroughly recommend
everyone to go follow you on twitter so
that whenever you start whatever it is
that you start
uh the people can can follow that and
engage with it because
you know it's been a brilliant interview
francis did you know that
investing is one of the best ways to
preserve your wealth over the long term
what's well something you will never
find out as long as i have control of
the trigonometry account
however if you do have wealth high
commission and clunky products
from traditional stock brokers make it
very difficult for people like me
to start investing good for everyone
else though
free trade has come up with an
award-winning app that is currently
being used by over 250
000 people it's fca approved and fscs
protected it's brilliant it allows you
to trade commission free
free trade has won best online trading
platform at the british bank awards
two years in a row 2019 and 2020.
they offer no speculative products no
spread betting no day trading
it's all about preserving and growing
your wealth over long term
no hidden fees transparent price and
structure very simple to use
you can sign up for a general investment
account or a stocks and shares
isa or sign up to free trade plus for
more advanced order types and a bigger
stock universe
they've also got other new products
coming soon you can get a universe go to
free trade dot io
trigger register and fund your account
and you'll get a randomly allocated free
share
worth between three and two hundred
pounds could be in a great company like
right move apple even greg's great so
when you invest your capital is at risk
the value of your investments can go up
as well as down and you may receive back
less than you originally invested you
knew that bit off by half
the question i really wanted to ask
before we get to our last question is
uh is there anything you wanted to add
because i have a sense that you might
you might have something to add to this
conversation of your own
uh well in in in what capacity i mean
i don't know i just have a feeling that
you might you might have something to
say
um well follow me on twitter at cliftona
duncan
um or on instagram my clifton duncan lie
online
um i but i think
that we are
there's more of us out there than than
we know
and i think that people who are afraid
should take heart
and and be courageous and say you know
i'm not taking this anymore and don't
allow yourself to be
to be bullied and you know i'm somebody
who
i don't really view myself as this huge
you know courageous person i have people
who are calling me that uh or
i had someone on twitter so you know
you're one of my favorite thinkers right
now i'm like if you're relying on some
you know no-name actor to be
a great thinker then we have serious
problems right now
and um well you're not wrong we do have
serious problems right now
well what we do and
i have a really hard time watching um
watching what i feel is the the
destruction of just
everything that makes being human
human you know if everything that ev
we're in this strange time now where
people are are
you are are completely incapable it
seems of looking at problems from a wide
perspective or taking
the long view of things and
i i try to think of how how what what i
can contribute
and and where i fit into all of this and
i think as an actor and as an artist
you know and frankly i mean i have a
diver my friends are actually diverse in
terms of their opinions so i know where
i sit
and i you know i have friends who lean
more to the right of me who
who make fun of me for being a bleeding
heart and
it and i think that my bleeding heart
and my openness
is one of the reasons i feel like like
i'm a more liberal-minded person
but it it's it's also why i have
sympathy
for instance for people who who voted
for donald trump and
you know people i mean people people
lost marriages they've disowned family
members
they've cut off lifelong relationships
and it's the same thing is happening
with cove but i was talking to a friend
yesterday who's in california right now
and if you're in new york or
if you're in california you have no idea
how much more close to normal life is in
places like atlanta where i
am right now and there is this divorce
from i'm i'm just really shocked to see
the number of people who said yeah
we don't need to socialize for a year
it's fine we don't have to be human we
don't
yo you're depressed you know you're
beating your wife and your kids uh you
know you have
you you have alcoholism whatever you're
dealing with that whatever but we have
to stay
safe by killing other people
in other ways you know and uh
the i go back to curiosity and empathy
um
as a cornerstones of of acting but also
i think we need to return to those sorts
of things just as human beings in our
society we need to have more curiosity
about
about the other people and and it's it's
it's astounding to me because when i i
talk to people and uh you know i mention
someone like thomas soule and you know
they shut down they say i'm not going to
even engage with this i'm like well you
really might want to read what he has to
say because
it might make you think differently and
it's so exciting to you know see people
like jordan peterson who's
inspired me to go on this intellectual
journey i feel like i'm playing ketchup
in so many ways i'm reading these
russian authors i'm reading
jung i'm reading nietzsche now i'm i'm
you know or
the conservative um commentator victor
davis hanson who's a classicist who now
has me
reading homer and going back and doing
all the things that i should have done
uh in my in my public education right
now and
it's exciting to me and there's so many
things flooding through my mind and i
can contribute all of these things to
the work that i do and what i create but
there's an active effort to shut out all
of these things and i'm like how can you
do that
like my life is so much more rich and
exciting now and there's so much more
interesting people in it
um just because i'm on this this
journeys
but i would never be on this journey if
i wasn't a more curious person
and if i didn't have empathy or try to
have some kind of empathy or put myself
in the shoes of the other person which
is which is what i'm paid to do
essentially
and um you know it's just there's a
there's a death there's a lack of
curiosity and a lack of
this thirst and hunger for ideas by
people who are telling me that i'm
ignorant and uninformed
that i should be educated you know it's
like i don't know if you're the dumbest
smart people or the smartest dumb people
but i'm sorry i'm sort of tired of
dealing with you and and the irony is
that once you begin to read all these
things and once you begin to explore
these ideas you
you become humbled by how much you just
don't [ __ ] know
and i remember when i was more of a
progressive minded person and i
end and you know like prime example
barack obama was given the nobel peace
prize which he obviously earned and made
and made good on
um subsequently and you know
there's a lot of people at weddings in
pakistan that might not agree
yeah yeah you mean all the all the
militants
yeah and in their in their bridal gowns
but uh yeah
you know but i you know this person had
the audacity to point out to me
on facebook no less that um that barack
obama had done absolutely nothing to
earn his nobel prize
and it it and it was just like the npc
meme i'm sitting there and i read it
i processed it it was loading for a
little bit
and then i was like you're a hater
hahaha you're a hater slam my laptop
[ __ ]
there's no attempt whatsoever to engage
with the truth of what this person just
said the simple truth of what this
person just said and that's what we're
seeing i feel like at large
um at least in this sect of society it's
this refusal to engage because i'm so
sure that where i am is unimpeachable
that uh you know you can't even i i just
have to be clever and funny
and snarky and and cool but i stay
stupid as a result
and i feel like there's there's you know
just mass stupidity going on but
it's masquerading as intelligence and
moral
and moral superiority that's that's
that's i could rant for hours obviously
about all kinds of things you know but i
just i just see it and i just ca
and i i observe and i just can't shut up
about it and i feel like more people
need to need to talk about it
and call it out amen and a woman
[Laughter]
yes yes absolutely but clifton thank you
so much for coming on the show
uh it's been an absolute pleasure um you
you
if people wanted to follow you you've
already said that uh earlier on but
just repeat again very very quickly yes
i am on twitter
at clifton a duncan and i'm also on
instagram
at clifton duncan online i also have a
youtube channel
uh called clifton duncan which i'll be
uploading content to regularly i started
uploading shakespearean sinus and then
my computer died so i wasn't able to do
it anymore
but you know i'm going to finish that
project and also begin to upload
more entertainment focused um uh
work as well uh you know i that i feel
like that could be my unique
contribution to the content creation
alternative sphere
you should definitely go for i'm gonna
go and subscribe to youtube channel
straight away and i recommend everybody
else
does as well because as i said there's a
lot of great things to come out of you
i have no doubt uh but we've got one
more question for you which is always
the one we always finish on which is
what is a one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
the one thing we're not talking about
but but we really should be it's such a
an easy and simple question
i think one thing that we're not talking
about that we really should be talking
about
is courage how far
are we willing to allow ourselves to be
pushed
into the realm of things that we know
are not
true how
do we develop the ability to
measure our compassion with practicality
um i mean how how how
ah i just i i i want to answer this
question and be like really brilliant
and articulate but
there's so many things um
uh to it i guess i just have to go back
to
what it means to be a human being and
to be alive you know and my my job as an
actor is to
is to be a conduit of all of those
things and
i i i i think the more technologically
advanced that we become and especially
the more
atomized that we become it becomes
really incumbent upon us to reach out to
people i mean i've been so heartened
by being down here in atlanta when
you're outside of this progressive
bubble in in a
in a blue city like new york you know
you're talking to your your your lyft
driver your uber driver you're talking
to
the the clerk at the the rite aid of the
cvs and
you realize that people people are
people
and they have issues and they have
problems they want to fall in love they
get angry they get jealous
they they go through despair and these
are the things that are important these
are the things that we should be
focusing on and improving in our lives
and
the less time that we spend watching
watching the quote unquote news the less
time we spend
[ __ ] all over each other on social
media and the more that we reconnect
to each other i mean it's going to sound
like a sappy
can't we always get along kind of
message and again this is the bleeding
heart in me
but i feel like now more than ever there
are so many forces that are trying to
to pull us apart and we need to just
come together
more you know i cautioned my friend the
other day or yesterday i said you know
just
i i i have a problem with people who
place responsibility on others for the
spread of an infectious disease that i
mean you can't really control
the path of a virus it's just yet
another tool people are using
to place me in the good camp and you and
the other camp and
i think people need to ask themselves
who benefits from all this division
because it's not us it's definitely not
us and um
so if if that if that were the the a bit
of a meandering response but
if that were the question i'd say you
know people need to be talking more
about what makes us human and what
and what unites us and binds us as
people and not just
those who are alive today but from
expanses of time one of the great things
about reading all these old plays and
all this old literature is you find that
even though technologies change
customs change civilizations change what
motivates people has been the same thing
for thousands of years
we were part of this rich human chain
and this rich human experience and
you know we need to be very careful
about
um preserving that and we don't want to
squander it
over [ __ ] it's a really really
lovely way to finish the
interview thank you so much for coming
on christian um thank you we really
really do appreciate it was a brilliant
interview guys if you've enjoyed the
show thank you so much
all our interviews and live streams go
out 7pm
uk time six days a week and we will see
you very soon make sure you go and
subscribe to clifton's youtube channel
and we'll see you very soon take care
bye bye
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below